my house got broken into in venice yes
my house got broken into
my neighbor walked by and he goes to
your garage and your gates open you know
i said what's neighbor but but so i go
[ __ ] you know
and uh
so my house gets broken into did they
steal seven black shirts well
what's interesting
he goes he goes well it's really weird
because your your wrestling mat is laid
out and your weights
are all
kind of lined up maybe they get a little
workout in oh oh and then your bicycle
is on your treadmill
what and i go what and then he goes yeah
go inside and
liquid death that i got a bunch of this
there's like there's a tower of liquid
deaths and then on the on the toilet
is a bunch of books these books are
lined up neatly and then on upstairs
toilet books and towels
and then on the laundry thing is like um
he took um
uh like little like gadgets like i don't
know like like whatever and made a cross
how do you know it's a he i don't you
sex as [ __ ] you're right i don't but
either way
this gentleman then took half my chairs
put them on top of oh you know what this
table it's called a creepy crawly
manson's family used to do this is this
true yeah they go in and [ __ ] with
everything just to confuse you uh-huh
and then they come back and murder you
she had a very expensive purse it was
turned upside down but they didn't take
it they didn't take nothing nothing was
taken
he just this person just did just put a
lot of weird [ __ ] everywhere just when i
admit to you that was me
a trauma and that was my so i was so i'm
looking around it's called creepy
crawling anything that's been missing
and no it was
they call it a creepy crawly i do now
yeah i didn't have the dogs there for
only this weekend you have guns too
right i got guns
yeah so you have guns dogs problems
cameras but when you leave you don't
leave the dogs
the only reason i gave the dogs to to
the ex when i when i left yeah that was
the only one some german shepherds my
german shepherd ain't letting not to
have cameras in venice though are you
out of your mind yeah well especially
that area we made some we've made some
changes some big changes yeah you got it
[ __ ] yeah you got it because at least
they didn't take anything not a thing
but let's be honest
what would they take my flat screen dude
my scooters yeah there you go like okay
i mean not but not much you know like my
clothes you're going we don't have like
anything like that i don't have anything
no they'd be like you probably when i
was like oh [ __ ] just [ __ ] everything
up there's nothing to do yeah but it was
no i think it was just one person who
was just weird
yeah they called a creepy crawly to
scare you yeah that's not the man so
they come back and murder you oh so i
gotta be ready i would be ready at all
times have you german shepherd yeah i
don't need that i'll be ready please
please come in with with the intention
of the only problem is pop is on the
road a lot and you got to post about it
so they know when you're gone
yeah you don't think about that
but i do have i do
i'm sorry that's so aggressive yeah i'm
sorry
i i was i
uh the lack of creativity
he's here
you don't think about that do you [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh i didn't hear the [ __ ]
smart i just heard you don't think about
it i know you didn't hear that
hey you don't think about it do you [ __ ]
face but i heard the [ __ ]
i ran out of [ __ ] my face is
aggressive